that was always like an outfit outlet
for me when I was depressed when I was
sad or felt anxiety I would literally go
to the studio and just like dance forget
about everything for hours yeah that's
what that is exercise
you escape yeah yeah
and it was my escape and so I feel like
I had an injury and so that's most of
the reason why I kind of had to pause on
Dance for a while with my neck and it
was just surgery no I didn't but it was
actually two neck surgeries really yeah
play sports my whole life I'm always in
pain it's it's life it's it's just I
don't know okay people have pain
not like me but go on yeah and I and I
still like struggle with it I did my own
stunts this is kind of I learned my
lesson there too yeah and I just
basically messed up my ligaments a disc
one of my discs did you yeah yeah I know
those yeah did they put you to sleep for
the injection I liked it
up to four
yeah you know what's funny is people
always say
when they put you to sleep on your
fridge you're gonna die I'm like I won't
know yeah I'll be dead it's true I'll
fall asleep and I'll die that's the best
way to go if that happens God forbid
that all right it's been hit by a car
and living through it yeah maybe you
know what's very interesting yeah what
redheads we take double the anesthesia
what yes are you aliens I guess so
double the anesthesia no no kidding and
this this one I was talking to the other
day she's a natural redhead her hair is
black now she has to tell him before or
hear her whoever is doing her um
anesthesia like I'm a natural redhead
and then they know I gotta up the dosage
really isn't that wild uh yeah it is
wild I've never heard that have you
heard that yeah but let me tell you
something I I don't do drugs
um I barely drink uh but whenever I have
to have an epidural and they put me to
sleep
can't wait it's it's like a weird
addiction it's like I don't go go get
them every day but like you know once
every eight months sometimes you know
whatever sometimes a couple in a year
yeah but when I go that morning I'm like
the anesthesiologist comes over doctor
[__] you not krakororkian
wears a bandana kind of hippie dude I'm
like listen Dr Krikorian
I um and I do this every time you know I
don't do any drugs you know I I barely
drink
this is like my only time to really feel
good if not for you know
for and what I'm saying to you is I
don't I don't want to be injected with
this stuff
and then fall immediately to sleep let
me enjoy it for a few minutes
let me just enjoy it and lie here and
feel good for a few minutes and he goes
absolutely
so he does it little by little so I can
kind of enjoy it wow I mean it's not
here's the funny thing
I wake up and I'm like oh yeah I'm just
groggy
and he comes over and I go dude
he said you're gonna let me feel it for
a few minutes he goes I did
you don't remember filming yourself on
your phone I go I looked at my phone it
was like three minutes hey what's going
on Hey listen to this joke and the
talking to all the nurses and laughing
and I'm like oh my Lord oh my God it was
hysterical and I was like wow isn't it
the weirdest feeling though when you
wake up and you're just
that is the craziest part for me is when
I wake up and I'm like we're done like
how long was that do you still get them
yeah I still get
um epidurals for my neck I'm like about
to go in in January does your doctor Dr
Port no Dr Bajaj
sounds fancy